une éternité une éternité qu'on a
cherché ça y est on l'a retrouvée où ça
non et alors
elle était là quand tu commences à
perdre pas tortue et que tu la retrouves
pas tu t'inquiètes mais là
le problème
[Musique]
c'est très bien le p deux réunions alors
philippe aujourd'hui on va démarrer la
fin auxerre jeu c'est chiant je fais
très bien levé sec hayon arrière four
n'ai pas senti en boîte je suis bien
enfin bon je fais très bien le pde
lendemain de boîtes de nuit au lion hier
on s'est mis de caisse avec lequel à
5h10 je suis désolé chez rien je fais
très bien le le p je peux le faire celle
ci peut le perdre on s'en fout du
jeu très bien le p de sodomie je me
retire serge
c'est le plus silencieux tu sais si o
phillips est chiant ah ben oui mais
coûteux
sa valise
[Rires]
[Musique]
rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]